am i right not a real doctor but a PhD
doctor which still counts to be a doctor
to my left secretary Melissa de Rosa who
is the top state official appointed
state official pleasure to be with her
it's a pleasure to be in Rochester today
really around the coit but for most
people they'll relate to Rochester it's
a pleasure to be in the Rochester
Regional health facility and I want to
thank the president CEO Erik Bieber very
much for having us here today
I also were joined by a number of
elected officials I want to thank them
for being here we have County Executive
Adam Bello pleasure to be with you we
have that great congressman who had a
really challenging position before he
went to Congress because he was working
in New York state government but he's
now in Washington and he's we needed his
voice there more than ever this is going
to be a big week in Washington we need
to get the federal government to
recognize the situation that state
governments face and fund not just
corporate America but fund working
Americans police firefighters
schoolteachers they have yet to do that
to the extent necessary and hopefully
with the leadership of the house we'll
get that done this week we have Robert
Duffy who is former mayor of Rochester
my great lieutenant governor for in the
first term pleasure to be with him as we
go forward we have elected officials
here with us today I also asked the
elected officials all across the state
to join us to understand today's
presentation so we invited all the
county executives we invited all the
mayor's to listen to this presentation
because we start a new chapter today in
many ways it's a new phase if you will
May 15th is the end of the statewide
closure May 15th is the end of this week
and the question is now going to shift
more towards localities
and regions across the state to make
sure they're in a position to open and
the state will be working in
coordination with them but it's an
exciting new phase we're all anxious to
get back to work we want to do it
smartly we want to do it intelligently
but we want to do it and that's what
this week is going to be all about in
terms of where we are total
hospitalizations or down again that net
change is down again
the net change in intubations is down
again the number of lives lost still too
high
obviously at 161 but better than it has
been so we see all the arrows are
pointed in the right direction if you
look at the number of new kovat cases
per day about 488 that is just about
where we started this horrific situation
right so May 10th we're right about
where we were in March 19th before we
went into the abyss of the kovat virus
and when you see the number of lives
lost again we're right about where we
started before we really went into the
the heart of this crisis and that's what
it's been it's been a crisis and a
painful one but we're coming out of the
other side so in many ways from my point
of view were on the other side of the
mountain right we got hit with the virus
we saw that incline we saw the number of
cases growing so the number of deaths
growing we finally hit a plateau because
we did what we needed to do and we
changed our behavior and we closed down
and we we turn the corner and then we
started to come down the other side and
that was the decline and now that the
client has gotten to a point where we
are just about where we started the
journey so to turn to reopening
because we have abated the worst by what
we've done and now we can intelligently
turn towards reopening and that's May
15th that's this Friday and local
regions all across the state should
start to prepare for it and people as
well and that's what we want to start to
talk about today we're going to open
when we're ready to open
what is ready to open mean well first
the number of hospitalizations the
infection rates show decline the federal
government that with CDC guidelines have
laid that out and we think it's
intelligent we have set the federal
guidance and we have testing tracing in
place in every local region testing and
tracing words we never really heard
before this situation but now people
have hear them every day testing have
the capacity to do enough tests
diagnostic tests are you positive or
negative antibody tests that you have
the virus and have you resolve the virus
have that testing capacity in place
tracing when you find a positive case
trace it back and then isolate the
positive so you reduce the spread sounds
simple logistical nightmare never been
done before but that's what testing
tracing is all about and that has to be
done region by region that capacity has
to fit every locality we talk about
being New York tough and what tough
really means and the second word in New
York tough is always smart and we have
been smart through this and we have to
continue to be smart there are seven
metrics if you will to get it down to a
quantifiable situation that each region
has to look at first are the infection
rate the number of hospitalizations the
14 day decline in hospitalizations or
under 15 new hospitalizations that means
you're controlling the hospitalizations
new hospitalizations under two per
so you know that the virus again is
under control then number four let's
learn from the past we had a true public
health emergency that we were in danger
of overwhelming our hospital capacity
let's make sure we have 30% buffer in a
number of available hospital beds in
case that virus takes off again on you
you want to make sure we have hospital
beds so hospitals up to 70% but 30%
available hospital beds 30% available
ICU beds many of the people come in with
this virus need an ICU bed we want to
make sure we have the ICU beds if if we
need them god forbid and then testing
capacity so we know what the virus
spread is doing you don't know what the
virus is doing unless you are testing
and then the tracing that fits with the
testing program we've been doing more
tests than any state in the United
States of America
so New York is way ahead in what we're
doing on testing we've come up to speed
faster we're doing more tests per capita
than any country on the globe so we're
doing very well in that regard but you
need it in every region it doesn't help
the Finger Lakes if the Capitol district
has enough testing you have to have
enough testing and enough tracing in the
Finger Lakes so each region has to have
that in place and we understand that we
can measure this this has always been
about data and science for us and you
can look at it each individual region
and you will know where each region is
in the state by those criteria so you
know what your infection rate is you
know what your hospitalization rate is
you know how many tests you need in
place you know how many tracers you need
in place this can be a science it can be
measured right and that's what we want
to do we want to do
mystify this entire issue sounds like a
science fiction movie I know I feel like
we've been living a science fiction
movie but you can also study it and
analyze it because we have a lot of
experience now right
we've been living with this for months
other countries have lived with this for
months
so let's learn let's be smart that's who
we are and we can do that by each region
in this state and you see depending on
the region in the state some regions are
ready to go today they just need to get
some logistical pieces in order by the
end of the week
some places are very close central New
York just one or two criteria that
haven't been met yet
and you can do that with Long Island New
York City all across the state when we
reopen we're talking about a phased
reopening that's what everyone basically
is doing the question is moderating that
phasing and doing it intelligently but
starting with construction and
manufacturing retail curbside pickup
agriculture forestry and fishing then to
phase 2 phase 3 phase 4 monitoring all
along we start with businesses that are
more essential and pose a lower risk
right because once you say we're gonna
reopen they say well what what first
well really everybody says me first
after me first
what businesses first those that are
most essential and those that pose a
lower risk because you can socially
distance etc that's the matrix to make
the decision and then businesses have to
do this their part also this is not a
one-sided affair businesses have to put
safety precautions in place we
understand what has to be done how the
workforce has to have personal
protection they have to be socially
distanced the work space itself in some
cases has to be adjusted reconfigured
how do you have people work but they're
6 feet apart they don't come to a
cafeteria there's no gathering right
that's what we're trying to avoid and
then what process is that we have in
place to test those employees or if it
employs symptomatic you can get them
testing right away you can then do
tracing within the workforce you look at
what's going on around the country just
listen to the news those meat processing
plants where you have hundreds and
hundreds of workers getting sick we have
an agriculture plant in Madison County
that dozens of people got sick it's not
about the meat or the agriculture it's
the gathering it's the density that's
what creates the problem so learning
those lessons and making sure we don't
make those mistakes here on retail all
retail will be authorized to do curbside
pickup or drop-off or in-store pickup
the essential retail which we've been
has been open along all along will
continue operating under the current
protocols will also open certain
businesses statewide which are low risk
landscaping gardening low-risk
recreational activities like tennis
drive-in movie theaters talk about going
back to the future
back to drive-in movie theaters I'm okay
with that by the way local officials
they have to do their work and their
responsibility testing and tracing they
have to have those systems in place we
have to have a system in place
regionally to monitor the infection rate
with the hospitals that connection has
to be very close they have to know on a
day-to-day basis if not an hour-to-hour
basis how many people are walking into
the hospitals I often do
conference calls with all the hospitals
in the state to find out exactly what is
going on because they can tell you how
many people walk through the door that
morning or that afternoon and you want
to be able to watch that and that has to
be done on a regional basis businesses
have to follow these new rules but we
have to make sure they're following
those rules also and you will get calls
from employees who say I went back to
work but by the way I'm not comfortable
I don't think this is appropriate social
distancing I don't think I'm giving been
given the the appropriate equipment
regional governor governments have to be
in a position to respond to those the
local governments have to be in
communication with each other we do this
on a regional basis so there are a
number of counties in that region but
it's one region and you know this virus
doesn't respect County borders or state
borders those governments have to be in
contact with each other if you know
what's happening with your neighbor you
know what's happening in your district
so that has to be in place and that has
to work and there's also something we
call a regional control room which is
made up of the top officials government
officials academic officials healthcare
professionals that are watching the
situation in that region developed you
are going to increase activity depending
on how intelligently you increase
activity will be the possible effect on
the spread of the virus you need to know
what the impact is you need to know it
in real time and you need to be in a
position to respond if it does not go
well and you see that infection rate
moving because the hospitals tell you
they see an increase or because you're
testing data shows an increase
you have to be able to pull the plug or
slow down the increase in activity and
that's what we call the circuit breaker
right so you're increasing the activity
you're watching the infection rate
you're watching the hospitalization rate
you see that start to tick up you have
to have a circuit breaker slow down the
activity level because you're increasing
the infection rate and nobody wants to
be there that means you're going back to
the other side of the mountain and we
just made it over the mountain nobody
wants to go back to the other side of
the mountain so those regional control
groups are very important they have to
be in place they have to communicate
everyone has to know what each other's
responsibilities are going forward and
we have been working with the regions
all across the state over the past few
weeks we have those groups assembled but
this week it's Monday before Friday
start talking start communicating
understand who does what where and
that's true in regions all across the
state but I would urge them now to get
on the telephone or zoom or whatever the
your preferred technology start talking
start understanding what happens on
Friday what do our numbers look like and
let's get that all set sooner rather
than later this is the next big step in
this historic journey first phase was
figure out what we were dealing with
because we had no idea
scramble frankly to deal with a
situation that dropped from from another
planet stabilized ramp up the healthcare
system inform people get people to
understand what we were
dealing with and control the damage
that's the mountain to me we're now on
the other side of the mountain next step
how do we reopen how do we reopen
intelligently and how do we reopen
without taking a step back well what we
have done thus far is really amazing and
it was because we were smart and because
we were unified and because we did that
we averted tragedy let's just remember
where we were right remember where you
were before you take a step forward
we had the virus that attacked us from
Europe the virus was coming they now say
the experts now say the geniuses now say
the virus came from Europe in January in
February and you know what no one knew
no one know with all the sophistication
with all the Public Health
Organization's with that whole alphabet
soup of agencies nobody knew the virus
was coming from Europe everybody's
looking at China and the virus is coming
from Europe
why because by the time we moved the
virus had traveled from China to Europe
and then people are getting on flights
from Europe coming to New York two
million travelers two million travelers
came from Europe we had no idea so New
York the East Coast people were landing
at JFK they were landing at Newark
Airport and that's where the virus came
from January February March
nobody knew European travel ban goes
into effect mid-march it's too late it
was already here
okay let's learn the lesson going
forward but that was the situation those
were the cards we were dealt that's why
New York had such high numbers not
because there's anything special or
different about New York but because New
York is where the European flights were
coming in
and we didn't know that was the
situation that we were handed they then
say well we project hospitalizations to
be 120,000 I said 120,000 you know how
many hospital beds we have in this state
50,000 how can we have hospitalizations
of 120,000 if we only have 50,000 beds
counting every bed in the entire state
of New York if you could coordinate
every bed you are 53,000 beds and they
projected 120,000 so scramble to try to
get more hospital beds but the only real
course was you have to reduce the
infection rate how do you reduce the
infection rate you have to close down
stop people from spreading stop
gathering stop density we did that
otherwise thousands more people would
have died thousands more would have died
that is not rhetorical that is not
dramatic that is a factual statement
thousands more people would have died we
made that happen we change that
trajectory I didn't even know it was
possible at one time when this started
we were at a truly bad and frightening
place if we didn't change the trajectory
of this virus and we had a hundred and
twenty thousand people show up at our
hospitals we would have made the
situation in Italy look like a walk in
the park we were really at a very very
bad place again through no fault of our
own virus came from Europe whoever would
have figured that somebody should have
but both my paygrade we changed the
trajectory dramatically by what we did
and that was smart but we have to stay
smart and we have to stay united you
look at what we've done
New York the cases are now on the
decline you look at the rest of the
nation outside of New York the cases are
still on the incline we took the worst
situation in the nation and changed the
trajectory so now we're on the decline
the rest of the nation the cases are
still on the incline that is because of
what the people in this state did if you
had said when we started this yes we
have more cases than anyone else yes we
had this European virus attack us and
nobody expected it but we're not only
going to change our trajectory we're
going to change the trajectory more
dramatically than anyplace else in the
nation and when you look at the nation
compared to New York you're going to see
us under the klein the rest of the
nation on the incline people would have
said it was impossible but we did it but
we have to stay smart on this next phase
we have to learn from the mistakes that
others have made and we're not the first
to reopen and that's a good thing
because you can look around and learn
other countries reopen too fast they
didn't have controls in place and they
reopened and then they had to slow down
or they had to stop we don't want to do
that we want to monitor our reopening so
if there's any change we can immediately
calibrate it some states have not
coordinated their actions so you have
one County doing this another County
doing this you've confused the general
public and by the way Monroe County
cannot open in and of itself
Onondaga County cannot open in and of
itself Albany County cannot open in and
of itself there is no County by
County plan here it has to be
coordinated and it has to be at least in
a region and we did that other states
didn't it was smart and there's one set
of rules and the public has to
understand the set of rules some states
are opening even though they haven't met
the CDC guidelines which I don't even
know how that happens the federal
government says here at the CDC
guidelines which are basic health
guidelines some states don't meet those
guidelines and they're opening anyway
well there's a lot of pressure to open I
know
but pressure doesn't mean you act
unintelligently right
some states opened and then saw a rush
of people from surrounding states we've
talked about that here concept of an
attractive nuisance Finger Lakes opens
you can't open up an attraction or a
site that will be attracting people from
outside the region and then you have a
problem you never encountered right so
that's something to watch and some
places never really made the people part
of the plan and that is a fundamental
mistake because this is not we are not
at a point where government is going to
solve anything frankly this is people
who are solving the problem personal
opinion as opposed to facts I did one
thing right as governor that I'm proud
of I got the people involved in this
situation to a greater degree than they
had been involved probably in modern
history probably in modern history from
day one this was of such a magnitude
that unless people engaged and
understood and bought into this
government was impotent government state
government can't impose enforce any of
these things that we did stay in the
house closed every school closed
every business state government can't
enforce that people had to understand
the facts and people had to engage in
governing themselves in a way they
hadn't in decades I don't know what
happened I'm still trying to figure out
when government got to a place or when
society got to a place where people
would accept the lack of professionalism
from government the lack of competence
from elected officials
I don't know when government became so
political and it all became about
rhetoric rather than actual competence
but it happened somewhere along the way
that government could not handle this
situation people had to get engaged
people had to be informed and that's the
one thing I did right now they got
engaged because it mattered this is not
an abstract issue you're talking about
people's lives and people's health and
the health of their children so they
were interested they were engaged but
they were also informed and I worked
very hard every day to make sure they
knew the facts trust the people Lincoln
right and informed public will keep this
country safe true and that's exactly
what happened here and that's what we're
going to continue to do people need to
be part of this the whole plan that
we're outlining today is all down it's
online it's in a book people need to
understand exactly how we do this second
phase just the way they understood how
we were going to get over that mountain
and how we were going to flatten the
mountain they have to understand now how
we reopen and they have to be part of it
understand the plan hold me accountable
hold me accountable hold your local
officials accountable but people have to
be part of it and they have to know the
facts
know what we're doing because it's going
to come down to how people react and how
people behave and if they understand
what we're doing they will do it just as
I couldn't enforce any of this on day
one the local officials are not going to
be able to enforce it either
nobody's gonna mandate personal behavior
people have to wear a mask people have
to be smart when they show up at work
people have to be smart when they shop
they have to understand this is not the
floodgates are open go back do
everything you were doing be smart
nobody's gonna protect your health but
you know one's gonna protect your
children's health but you well children
aren't affected oh really that's another
fact that they're going to change on us
now we're worrying about we have 93
cases that were investigating of young
children who have Cova droll aidid
diseases so this is about keeping
yourself smart and keeping yourself
healthy and keeping your family healthy
we'll do everything we can but you have
to be New York tough smart is the first
word after tough United disciplined
loving thank you for being here any
questions as I said with this shift
right sort of going from phase one which
is basically a state controlled one set
of rules all across the state those
phase one this reopening phase is
locally driven regionally driven and
regionally designed so the businesses
that can open are the businesses that
are
to buy that region and approved with
these conditions right every business
that reopens is going to have to meet
certain conditions the state said a
certain number of conditions local
governments may add additional
conditions to those businesses
businesses and how they open and that
has to be done on a region by region
basis so how long do you anticipate it
taking to get to that point you can it
will it will be determined by the facts
and the numbers as you go along
right you are I'm a visual person you're
turning a valve increasing the economic
activity your question is how fast can
we open the valve you have a dial right
next to the valve that says infection
rate you have another dial that says
hospitalization rate you can open that
valve as fast or as slow to keep that
infection rate below 1.1 which is what
they call outbreak that hits one point
one means the virus is increasing
exponentially so watch that dial watch
the hospitalization rate and the timing
of phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 it's
determined by those two dials it's
determined by those facts you watch the
infection rate you watch the
hospitalization rate as fast as you can
come online without increasing the virus
spread to outbreak or increasing the
number of deaths then that's how fast
you reopen the economy
the local region has a control room and
a circuit breaker we call it to stay
with the graphic physical metaphor
circuit breaker if you see those dials
going into the red zone if you're really
closely watching the dials you wouldn't
have to turn the valve off you would
just slow the valve a little bit
depending on how well your dials are
calibrated and whether you're watching
or not so the best would be just slow
instead of off but if the dials go into
the red zone circuit breaker turn the
valve off until you get the dials back
under control we the whole ride across
the mountain has been getting the spread
of the infection under control what they
call the infection rate how fast it's
spreading it has to be under one which
is one person who is infected infects
less than one other person right you
have to keep the infection rate below
that and you have to keep the
hospitalization rate at a manageable
level you can't overwhelm your
hospital's period because then people
die and that is a universal bad thing
you watch those two dials and you
calibrate it locally well how fast can
you open nobody knows it also depends on
how smart you are in the opening now if
you open businesses and the employees
are smart and the business owners are
smart
well then theoretically nobody should
get infected right you should be able to
go to work be six feet apart from
everyone have the right precautions
nobody gets infected infected you do it
wrong you're at the meat processing
plants and the poultry processing plants
that we've seen across the nation you
open up everybody goes to one place a
few people have the infection and now
you have a thousand workers infected how
did that happen
it was improper precautions in the
workplace so you have to depends on how
businesses do how employees do and then
you watch those dials as fast as you can
reopen reopen just watch the dials how
long will the businesses in each phase
keep these plans in place like say how
long will they have to stay six feet
apart or one will it be okay to maybe
lift those plans it depends on the facts
you'll know you're watching your basic
question is when do we don't have to
worry about the virus anymore I hope
it's tomorrow I doubt it's tomorrow it
depends on how good we are at reducing
the spread and controlling the spread
it's how smart we are
it's our actions our behavior that's why
I come back to who slowed the spread in
the beginning the people of this state
nobody else there's no government action
it was an unprecedented action of the
people presented with the facts informed
and engaged hasn't happened in my
lifetime hasn't happened in my lifetime
I've never seen this situation before
where people actually did what the
founding fathers thought they would do
that they would really care and really
get engaged and really get informed and
really act on what they believe you know
for so many years what government did
was just irrelevant or overly political
or you didn't believe anyone you didn't
trust anyone so they just tuned it out
right I have to live my life I can't
watch this sideshow called government
politics yeah well now it's a matter of
life and death and they got engaged tell
you something or tortoise Lee I also
believe if we actually learn from
this moment you know we talked about
reimagining New York so that we don't
just build back we build back better and
we're going to do that I also think this
is a moment that could change history in
this country for the better you you
whoever the you is that started this
virus you had a wake-up call for this
country and a moment of in history that
people have never gone through before
you stopped the country
you stopped the economy you put we call
it pause in New York put people's lives
on pause and everyone went to a period
of turmoil and stress and reflection on
their own personal lives their family
lives their whole situation government
Society I think this is going to be a
real value a tional across the board and
I think we can be the better for it
I believe that I believe we individually
can be the better for it
I believe my kids are going to be the
better for it I believe I am going to be
the better for it
I believe my family is gonna be stronger
for it and I believe the state is going
to be better for it on an individual and
a collective level and I think people
are going to think about society and
government differently than they ever
did because it really really matters now
and they understand how government can
make a significant difference in their
lives and it's not going to be a
sideshow anymore they're not going to
tolerate it I believe that so they were
in charge the people they accomplished a
great great feat in this state we had
the worst situation in the nation the
worst and now our numbers on the decline
and the rest of the country is still on
the incline so but New Yorkers did
nobody could have imagined if they show
that same resolve and intelligence in
this next phrase it's up to them it is
up to them are there guidelines for day
care as we open it I didn't see it on
your graph there when code day cares
yeah yeah it's a very good point look we
said all along the closing of the
schools had a direct impact on what you
could do with the businesses right and
we said you couldn't open all the
businesses wholesale without opening
schools because you'd make it very
problematic how do people go to work
with their children or at home we said
we're not opening schools for the
remainder of the academic year so these
business openings until the end of the
academic year you're gonna be in phase
one phase two you're not going to have
all the businesses open but arranging
childcare for those workers who need it
are one of the responsibilities of these
regional councils you have to have
daycare available childcare available
for those workers who now are going to
go back to work I like the boyfriend
rule
[Laughter]
our region is doing and we can't seem to
get that data we know that you have it
and it's provided to you you're kind
enough to share it on a statewide basis
but again this is a regional website
where they provide information things
the metrics upon which the date of
reopening their basis you have said
you've worked very hard every day to
make sure that we get information and to
hold you accountable can you get the
state health department to start
releasing that information on a
consistent daily basis so folks all
involved in this can keep track of it
good question you're right
when can we put up the daily
hospitalization rate region by region
today will be public today so you can go
to a website you'll see how the regions
are doing it gets updated every 24 hours
starting today some work there's one
agency in charge of this they make it so
marelli call Joe Morelli phone number
202 thank you very much god bless you